[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to give it Dear John and
Hank it's a weekly podcast where I Hank
green and my brother John answer your
questions and give you dubious advice
and bring you all of the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon but
first John do you have a poem for us no
I do have a poem this morning but I
thought we could start by just talking
about how we're doing how are you oh I'm
okay my refrigerator still isn't running
so I wouldn't make a video on how to
deal with your refrigerator stopping
working because apparently it is not an
easy problem to fix well here's a broad
observation Hank and I hope that you
don't take this too personally but for
249 thousand eight hundred fifty of the
250 thousand years that humans have been
on this earth they haven't had
refrigerators and and we've done just
fine as a species so maybe you need to
suck it up ah fine do you want to tell
me do you want to tell me how you're
doing I'm doing great things are good
here my five-year-old son has just
started school and it's so cute with the
backpack and in his little school
uniform and everything it's just
adorable
i I couldn't be happier it's beautiful
summer here in Indianapolis the White
River is that it's a very very finest
life is good
and here is a poem by Emily Dickinson
tell all the truth but tell it slant
tell all the truth but tell it slant
success in circuit lies too bright for
our infirm delight the truth superb
surprise as lightning to the children
eased with explanation kind the truth
must dazzle gradually or every man be
blind I love this poem but I also don't
know what it means and I've loved it for
a long time and I felt torn in two
directions about it for the world for
the longest time because um one of the
things that's interesting about
Dickinson's poetry is the sort of waxing
and waning relationship that she has
with religious faith and with the idea
of the soul and I feel in this poem
there is both the wax
and the waning and I can handle one poem
waxing and another waning but I'm not
sure that I can handle waxing and waning
within the same poem but I love that
line tell all the truth but tell it
slant I think it is a really really good
piece of advice when it comes to telling
stories and also when it comes to
writing so that's that's today's poem
hmm I very rarely know what to think
about poems John Emily Dickinson in
particular is something that that was
that was forced upon me in high school
and I was like this is clearly just
somebody who put a bunch of words down
in in an order that to them and to us is
completely arbitrary and I need I need
you to give to teach me how to feel
things about these words that are
clearly meant to say something but are
so afraid of actually saying well the
problem with saying things directly I
mean that's a you know that's a
reasonable criticism of many poems and
many works of literature but the problem
with saying something directly is that
you you end up saying it less
effectively right like let me submit
that if you just say there is a certain
tension between innocence and experience
and adolescence that leads to a
simultaneous like thrill of the new and
feeling of loss about one's childhood
that one can never get back like that
isn't that doesn't hit you in the middle
you can't identify with that it doesn't
feel as transformative as like reading
about Holden Caulfield experiencing
those emotions so I think that there is
something about language that can be
like transformative and helpful in a way
that just quote-unquote saying something
isn't but yeah so I mean that's that's
that's what Emily Dickinson is saying I
think when she says tell all the truth
but tell it slant you know we can't if
we just say the thing directly a lot of
times it isn't as impactful it isn't as
as moving and
and important to us should we move on to
questions or do you want to continue
well I want to talk about poetry is that
okay okay okay yeah absolutely for a
little bit III will I will also submit
that you know like there there's a both
a problem and a solution in the way that
I feel like poetry operates the the the
solution is that it's giving us an
opportunity to think it's it's kind of a
it's a prompt we're in like it's not
saying here's the thing to think it's
saying here is something that will make
you think and I appreciate that I
appreciate I love things that make me
think and I think you know by not being
all up front and being you know a
hundred percent this is the thing that
I'm trying to say it gives you the
opportunity to fill it in the problem
that that solution also causes is that
it doesn't truly function unless it it
sort of relies on the reader and the
writer to have come from a similar place
in in that you know these well not
necessarily I think I think that it
relies on them having come from a
similar place if the reader is going to
get what the writer intended for them to
get well yes and no I mean look a reader
and a writer have to work in
collaboration and a reader has to do
their job just as the writer has to do
their job but like let me give you the
example of The Adventures of Huckleberry
Finn the great American novel written by
Mark Twain you know like there is a
there is a right way and a wrong way to
read that novel it's it's not just it
doesn't just exist to make you think it
exists to make you understand some of
the reasons that that slavery is so
unjust and that sort of like a demented
moral conscience across a social order
can lead to people believing that virtue
is sin and sin is virtue like that's
that's not trying to like make you think
it's trying to make an argument that
that will you know will change your
belief system or or affirm your
understanding of humanity or challenge
it and I think like that the idea that
like you know all readings of a story or
a poem are equally valuable or there are
no wrong answers in literature like
there are in science like I just
dismissed that completely I think that
you know III think that authorial intent
isn't particularly important but meaning
is and and there are better and worse
readings of a text and it's just like
science in the sense that our
responsibility as as readers is to try
to try to get to whatever truth might be
inside a work of art yeah III feel yeah
in in in the case of a novel I would
understand it much more of like the the
you know the amount of information there
allows for a more solid interpretation
but I think the economy of words in
poetry and also the you know the intent
of it being a little bit you know like
leaving room there for the for the
reader to be a part of the work it in a
way it I feel like without without you
know participating participation in
Emily Dickinson's culture I would have a
very difficult time understanding what
Emily Dickinson's work meant no I mean
it's right there in the text like you
know as lightning to the children eased
with explanation kind like you know we
don't tell young children like you know
lightning is this terrifying bolt of
electricity from the sky that will kill
you we're like oh listen to the you know
look at the beautiful lightning and then
hear the big thunder you know and her
argument here is right in the last two
lines of the poem the truth must dazzle
gradually or every man be blind like if
somehow you know the secrets of the
universe and and of God and the soul
were revealed to us
all at once that like this that truth
would be blinding now I don't agree with
the argument of the poem necessarily but
like I think there is a reading of it
like I don't think that it's like that
heart is I don't think it's like a
matter of like you know needing to
understand you know what kind of house
Emily Dickinson grew up in or like what
color clothing she wore I think it's it
was usually white for the record but I
think you know I think like the the the
poem can stand on its own
now not all poems can stand on their own
but I think that one can can we get to
the questions I think that's probably a
good idea all right this question is
from Ellie she writes dear John and Hank
my name is Ellie and I've been a
nerdfighter for over two years my
question to you is do you think there is
a possibility of there being different
universes do you believe in the
multiverse theory now I am NOT a
scientist Ellie so I'm gonna answer this
question first and then I'm gonna let
Hank who actually has information
related to the subject answer it I
totally believe in the multiverse theory
I believe that there is a universe in
which every possible thing that could
have happened happens where like a
butterfly flapped its wings this way in
one universe and that way in another
universe and that in and of itself made
a different universe and there is this
like nearly well I don't know if you can
really say nearly infinite because
infinity isn't a big number but there's
this like countless you know good
jillian's of universes out there and in
each of them interestingly Donald Trump
does not become president this is a
conversation John and I have previously
had that that if there is a possibility
that that all all things could happen
even even in that that infinite sphere
and none of them does Donald Trump win
the Republican nomination for president
there is two of them and and yet we
continue talking about it no I think
there's two of them out of the like 14
quadrillion possibilities I think there
are two in which he gets the nomination
but in neither of those two does he
become president
when in one of the two where he gets the
nomination my understanding is that
there is an asteroid that hits the earth
that results in there only being 17
Americans left but he still loses to
Samuel who was a manager at a meat
processing plant but wins you know the
majority of the vote he actually wins 16
to 1 in the end so le from to talk about
this in a more scientific way it's the
there's this idea of believing in a
scientific theory is sort of imagining
the way that science works incorrectly
so I think that sometimes we want there
to be a world that we can you know just
like can it kind of decide how we want
to see the world and and I think that we
should and can do that when it comes to
to personal relationships and to culture
but when it comes to the multiverse in
the universe we don't really get to
decide what we believe in there is a way
that it is and we don't know so we don't
know whether there's a multiverse or not
we have people who have proposed it
because there is complicated math that I
do not and do not want to understand and
they get they have they have that
argument and and they will continue to
have those arguments for probably a very
long time until until some day in which
they can say with relative certainty
that one or the other thing is true and
then we will continue on our path to
learning more about how how the universe
functions but but is it possible Hank
that there is this like nearly infinite
set of universes and that everything
that happens in the universe creates a
new one yeah
yeah Wow I mean when you start talking
cosmologically a lot of things are
possible first of all but yeah I mean
it's it's definitely a thing that has
been proposed and and has been worked on
and and in the way that cosmologists and
physicists deal with these things it has
been it has been scrutinized but it is a
very difficult thing to scrutinize
because at the point where we are
talking about the universe in terms of
equations and in terms of what we
observe it is a weird weird thing when
when it all boils down to math Wow this
question is from Maggie who asks dear
Hank and John if you could have any
three languages instantly downloaded
into your brain which would they be and
why well from my perspective it'd be
very helpful to have English all of
English immediately there are so many
English words that I need when I'm
writing that I find it difficult to
access or remember or like I'm trying to
use my brain as a thesaurus and it isn't
working so I would start with English
second would be Spanish a lot of Spanish
speakers in my life and I think it would
be fun to be able to speak Spanish also
I really like this this NPR show my
friend Daniel outer cone makes called
radio ambulant a but I can't listen to
it the the Spanish parts because I don't
speak Spanish and then the third would
be Mandarin because I I believe that you
know obviously that would be very useful
if we could make crash course world
history videos in Mandarin Spanish and
English instead of just English so those
would be my three yeah I think I'd
probably just picked the three most
commonly spoken languages that weren't
English I would not just try and get
more English because I feel like I'm
pretty good there but yeah giant
Mandarin Hindi and Spanish I believe are
the three most spoken languages English
is in the top the top four as well so I
I think you want to know the top five
spoken languages Hank am I wrong
Mandarin Spanish English
hindi and do you have a guess no I have
no idea it's actually minion what minion
like that like the little yeah the
little yellow thing yeah
minion is v it's actually Arabic that
was more of a joke for my son than a
joke for you but I enjoyed it greatly
you know what a weird the weird thing
about minions have you noticed this that
like minions are loved by children and
women over 65 hmm I'm not sure that
minions are loved by women over 65 I
don't think there's anyone over the age
of nine who really loves a minion right
now no no it's crazy it's I I was just
at a wedding shower at a at this so my
friend has a friend who is in her 60s
and her house is covered in minions
covered and she she has amazing she's an
artist she's a she's an amazing water
colorist and she does really beautiful
textile art and she is really
intelligent wonderful woman and she's
obsessed with minions and when you look
when the minions movie was first
announced there was uh you know the
trailer got shared on Facebook and it
was just all all comments from people in
their 60s being like well I know this is
for kids but I'll tell you what they
sure I can't wait
they love it they it's so strange we
should talk to mom about it and be like
mom Dee are you into minions I don't
think she is but maybe she would be I
don't know it's a weird I feel I really
think respectfully that you found one
person who happens to like minions it
happens to be a woman over 60 and you
made a very broad conclusion let's take
another question Hank this one's from
River Dear John and Hank I've watched
the world cup for a long time now I want
to start following the game full-time
but I don't know where to start because
it's very confusing
I chose Chelsea initially because I
liked the name but while I was put off
from them soon after presumably because
they were built from the blood of actual
Russian peasants anyway any tips for the
beginner soccer phone or how do you
choose your team well River it's not
easy but you chew
is AFC Wimbledon and then you realize
that you can't watch AFC Wimbledon week
in and week out because they play in the
fourth tier of English football so you
choose the other great club in England
Liverpool Football Club it's that easy
River done and dusted there's also a
question for you Hank will you be in
season two of that thing you're doing
with Wil Wheaton I will be and so little
on Kia and Jeremy if you if you're aware
of what we're talking about I did a show
called Titans grave the ashes of Val
Khanna with Wil Wheaton and some friends
in which we play the highest production
value session of a tabletop RPG that
you've ever seen so it's like Dungeons &
Dragons if you've heard of that but it's
not Dungeons & Dragons where we we take
on the role of characters and and fight
evil it's real fun and real good and
real funny and I just went to the
subreddit reddit.com slash are slash
forwards from grandma and it is full of
minions
sorry job are you serious yes but like
wait it's it's reddit slash are slash
what four words from Grandma I'm gonna
look cuz I don't believe wow that's a
lot of minions gracious let's move on to
another question this one's from Brianna
who writes Dear John and Hank
salutations my name is Brianna and I
fell out of a tree today I was climbing
a tree and I slipped and was in a
position where I could either fall on my
knees or jump and land on my feet I
chose the ladder but I was barefoot
because I find shoes rather cumbersome
and so I landed on the sidewalk and then
stumbled a few steps and curled into a
panting heap for a few minutes
some people drove by and looked
concerned so I decided I had to get up
so that no one called an ambulance
because I was fine just shaken once I
got up it felt like my body no longer
trusted my mind's decisions so I
couldn't run but I also couldn't stop
moving now I'm realizing that the story
is too long my question is what tree
climbing advice can you give me because
I rather like
trees we've ever got that's a really
good question Briana I have to say I'm
not a I'm not a super expert it sounds
like you may know a good deal more about
Klee trattman
tree climbing than I'd yeah I'm a little
confused as to why Briana reached out to
dear Hank and John or as I prefer to
think of it Dear John and Hank for tree
climbing advice when she seems to be the
world's leading tree climber yeah I
guess the first thing I'd say brianna is
when I set out to climb a tree even
though I do find shoes rather cumbersome
at times I put them on so that's my
number one piece of advice wear some
shoes yeah your ancestors were barefoot
for so long and they worked so hard to
make shoes possible for you over
generations and generations they they
toiled so that you could have shoes when
you climb trees whereas they could not
so wear shoes that's actually my main
piece of advice other than that it seems
to me that you're an expert tree climber
yeah I mean I'm very glad that you
didn't fall on your knees because that
would have been very bad knees are not
designed for being fallen on feet are
and yeah Hank how tall do you suppose
this tree was where she was able to land
and be unhurt I feel like if I fell from
a tree that was 3 or 4 feet above the
ground I would definitely break a leg
you could fall from higher than that it
turns out and be alright mm-hmm maybe
you can I'm old you get you start
getting into trouble once you get up
over 10 10 feet or so where you're where
you're pretty guaranteed to have to have
a broken bone or two Hank sometimes you
say things and you say them very
authoritative ly in the way that you
always say things and I can't decide if
you actually know all these things or if
you just have a gift for having a voice
that sounds like you know things like is
10 feet actually like the distance at
which injuries become far more likely or
are you just a confident liar ok yeah
we've got another question this one is
from Reid who asks dear Hank and John do
fish sleep if they do sleep what do you
think fish dream about any ideas John
Hank I know that there's nothing
more boring than other people's dreams
but can I tell you about my dream anyway
I dreamt last night that I was
imprisoned with Sara my beautiful wife
we were both imprisoned and we were
trying to find a way for one of us to
escape because our children were on the
loose they were having to take care of
each other and I love my five-year-old
son very much and he's an incredibly
good big brother but he is unqualified
to take care of Alice oh it made me very
anxious anyway I think when fish sleep
they have anxiety dreams just like we
presumably they dream of sharks and of
being eaten they dream of the world
without them which will indeed be the
world soon enough fish will be okay
there's a lot of ocean well not all of
them will be okay but I think I think
most of the fish will be all right Hank
yes Hank what Hank what none of them
will be okay none of the fish will be
okay they are all going to die every
fish every moment it's swimming knows
that oblivion is coming right age
individual fish will die yes and then
eventually all of the fish will die and
there will be no life on earth all right
let's can we get back to the original
question which is about whether or not
in the fish sleep do they're not really
a fish do not have eye eyelids so they
don't they can't close their eyes like
like we would win sleeping they also
don't do the thing that we do when we
sleep which is that we like power down
parts of our brains and like our brain
enters into a new a new way of operating
their brains aren't really that
complicated fish brains so they don't
really do that they do some fish like
rest they have resting periods but it
doesn't seem to be that it is the it is
it's more of a physical rest than it is
a mental a alteration in the mental
state the way that sleep is for us so
fish don't really sleep now and they
don't and and they and because of that
they don't dream Wow which is
interesting so fish don't dream about
sharks
yeah they don't dream down
they don't have anxiety dreams what a
lovely what a lovely thing do you think
fish feel anxious though because I feel
like they do like when I when I see fish
I always feel like they're super anxious
probably I I imagine that that all prey
animals have some kind of anxiety based
instinct let me ask a follow-up question
Hank would you consider humans to be a
prey animal No
then why do I have so much anxiety I
what we yeah I think that we certainly
are related to prey animals we're
closely related to prey animals and and
also I I think that there are a lot you
know do you I guess you don't have to be
a prey animal to experience exactly
there are lots of things to be anxious
about that aren't death and and you know
being consumed so I think that even if
it's you know your weight way where will
will will will back up back up back up
there are other things to be anxious
about
I've been devoting so much time to being
anxious about death that I didn't even
know but what are these other things
that I need to be worrying about please
list them immediately you know social
standing mates is that one of the
primary things that humans and other
animals are anxious about so you know
finding and securing someone to
procreate with and also who will love
you for being you
oh I quite like my mate and I'm
reasonably happy with my social standing
so that's a big relief so can I just
focus on death is that okay yeah that's
fine I mean that's actually like a sign
that you're good doing pretty good if
you're if you know you're focused on on
the you know the sort of most inevitable
and and unavoidable problem that we all
face that's good that's fine you know
that means that you're you've had you've
handled them more the more handleable
ones good job today's episode of dear
Hank and John is brought to you by the
fear of death the best fear
according to Hank today's episode of
dear Hank and John is brought to you by
feet you do not need to wear shoes on
your feet because of how cumbersome they
are
if you are climbing trees but maybe you
should anyway just for safety's sake
today's episode of dear Hank and John is
brought to you by grandma who wants you
to know that the minions movie will be
out on DVD soon today's episode of your
hanky John is brought to you by the
multiverse Theory completely unconcerned
with whether or not you believe in it
all right Hank just a couple more quick
questions before we get to the
all-important news from AFC Wimbledon
and I guess also the news from Mars this
question is from Klaus who is from
Germany and who asks dear John and Hank
how would you go about implementing the
metric system in North America let me
answer this question first cause because
I happen to know that Hank is is a
delusional fan of the metric system
because he believes in base ten numbers
instead of that sweet sweet base 12 that
we have here in the United States with
our 12-inch feet and our 12 feet per
square meter Hank is that correct that
was like a super cringe so let me answer
your question with a question Klaus why
on earth would we adopt the metric
system here in the great United States
of America when we already have an
excellent system of measuring distances
there are 12 inches in a foot there are
three feet in a yard and there are 5,280
feet in a mile could it be any simpler
the answer my friend is no well class
asks a question and if you think we
should actually answer it instead of
being intentionally obtuse we could do
that I wasn't being intentionally obtuse
I'd like that there are 5,280 feet in
miles it's so much easier to remember
them the number of meters in a kilo
meter Klaus I will answer your question
by just saying that it is indeed
difficult and I do not want to like be
too angry at America for not having
converted to the metric system because
it is a big and and diverse country with
a lot of needs
and a lot of a lot of systems that have
been put in place and would be very
difficult to to change from and it's it
yeah it's a big country it goes all the
way from one side of the continent to
the other and we are also very powerful
and there's a lot of efficiency in that
power and we can say like well we would
change except that everybody else is
completely willing to to to deal with
our weird system of measurements so that
they can do business with us so why
would we when it's gonna cost us money
and effort and annoyance to change so
there are good reasons why America
doesn't change to the metric system but
they are not they are there are
practical reasons that have to do with
economics and with efficiency they are
not they are not reasons that have to do
with just how how much more efficient
the whole world would be if everybody
used the same units we are not in a
perfectly global society and so we do
not function as a global society we
function as a unit of the United States
and we say well it's about us being more
efficient dealing and doing this using
the systems we've always used not about
the whole world being more efficient
trying to get all on one system of
measurement which would be obviously not
the system of measurement we use and
even Americans recognize that we don't
want the rest of the world to use our
stupid system but we we have a hard time
switching because we have a lot invested
into our current stupid system so I
really don't know and I don't think it's
gonna happen you know in a in the short
term I in the next 30 years I doubt we
will we will shift to the metric system
I'd I would love for it to happen and
science has largely shifted to the
metric system I you know use metric
measures for weight and distance myself
but I don't for temperature because that
just is very confusing to me and yeah I
I think that I also think that it's
perfectly reasonable and possible to be
a to system country and we kind of are
you know we function in both so that was
a long answer to classes very short
question in which I didn't actually
answer the question because I don't
think that we are going to do it I think
we'll do it but I think we'll do it when
we become less powerful on the global
stage and so that it makes more sense
for us to do it because we're losing you
know real measurable benefit from not
doing it but I will say that I think
that would be a sadly when it comes down
to it will be a very sad day because you
know how are we gonna know how far it is
from Los Angeles to New York you know we
won't even be able to calculate that
anymore distance will just be a thing
that we have to estimate using you know
like oh it's about four hundred thousand
human heads between Los Angeles and New
York if that'll be the only way that
we'll have a measuring distance this is
just the approximate width of the adult
human head I want to know how close you
actually were to the the real distance
400,000 human heads is that way about
way too much or way too few or roughly
correct I'm gonna do that math oh well
Hank first off it depends if you're
talking about the width or the length of
a human head because they aren't
perfectly circular so I'm sure someone
is going to figure that out for me but
I'm gonna guess that I nailed it based
on everything I know about myself Hank
it's time for the news from Mars a cold
dead Rock further from the earth than
the Sun that has no atmosphere to speak
of and also the news from AFC Wimbledon
the most exciting fan owned football
club in the world and arguably the
greatest institution that human beings
have ever come together to produce
what's the news from Mars this week well
and the news I'm sorry I was doing math
I mean Hank I got it exactly right it's
not hard just trust me
I know the width of a human hair sorry
I'm still doing math just a second you
were off
by a lot incorrect you've measured the
human head poorly but it's amazing you
you would think that a 400,000 human
heads laid laid side by side and in any
orientation would be a long way but it's
actually in on the order of you know
about a hundred to two hundred miles no
way
okay let's let's move out of the news
from from Mars John is that all right
with you yes please let's okay this week
NASA tested one of the oh not one of the
the most powerful rocket engine ever
developed one of the most efficient
rocket engines ever developed as well it
will be used on the Space Launch System
which will propel American astronauts
once again into space as we move beyond
the era where we are piggybacking on our
on the rockets of our Russian friends
and the the the engines are meant for
single-use they are they are crazy like
they're they're basically built to work
you know they're single-use engines so
you light them off and they rock it I
that was not meant to be a pun they rock
it so hard that they basically you know
are pretty close to the danger zone in
terms of engineering and failure but
that allows them to be very efficient by
having so much thrust they have a very
good thrust to weight ratio these are
the rs.25 engines and we we just did
sort of a final test that NASA did a
final test were they they ran one of
these engines on the ground and not
attached to a actual space vehicle and
and it went very well
and these will be the engines if we ever
take humans to Mars they will likely be
the engines that do it I'd like to
slightly adjust my estimate for the
number of human heads between Los
Angeles and New York from four hundred
thousand to forty million because I
think that four hundred thousand is
about thirty miles or thirty-five miles
but I think four
million is darn near perfect it's just a
quick forty million head plane ride from
Los Angeles to New York City I'm sorry
what was the news from Mars you guys
built a rocket it's super fast it's a
really great rocket it's like that's
that it's that that that the Ferrari of
rocket engines John it's gonna it's
gonna get us to Mars way faster and it's
gonna make really loud noises and a lot
of fire that's really exciting hey
congratulations on your new rocket hey
AFC Wimbledon won their first game of
the season they came from one nail down
against Crawley Town and won the game
two to one the first goal of the season
for AFC Wimbledon was scored of course
by the Beast
odda bio Aachen phenoix the player I
loved above all others at least among
current current players in England he's
the biggest strongest toughest English
football player and he's got dftba on
his shorts both of the first two home
games unfortunately have resulted in
losses so from three games AFC Wimbledon
has just three points that's not that's
not enough we need to start doing better
soon
but the John Green stand has sold out in
each of the first two games so that's
something but ya won a game two to one
you know what they say Hank one-nil down
to two one up that's the way we're gonna
get promoted to lead one so it's very
exciting
I am hopeful about the season but but of
course a little nervous about our start
here just three points from the first
three games and that's the news from AFC
Wimbledon what oh what a wonderful time
in your history John I'm excited for you
that's nice you did a good job of faking
it I do my best because what you feel is
completely valid hmm I feel the same way
about what you feel but just less so Oh
John okay so what did we learn today we
learned that you should probably wear
shoes when you're climbing a tree and we
learned that apparently
grandmother's love minions the fifth
most popular language spoken in the
world today we also learned that John
would rather learn English than a
language that would allow him to talk to
hundreds of millions of people I'm just
trying to become a better writer Hank
and of course we learned thanks to Elli
that there may or may not be a
multiverse but regardless the multiverse
doesn't care if we believe in it and in
one of those universes John in one of
those universes AFC Wimbledon just won
the World Cup no nope actually they
didn't in none of those universes
because AFC Wimbledon could never
possibly compete in the World Cup
because they are not an independent
nation but in one of those universes and
what are those universes they are they
are an independent nation just that
little town it's like the Vatican the
inside of England and then they win the
World Cup that was great and I want to
thank everybody for for listening to
this episode of dear Hank and John also
thanks for submitting your questions
which you can continue to do at Hank and
John at gmail.com we'll endeavor to
answer as many as possible in future
podcasts our theme music is from
gunnarolla this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins
we are John and Hank green and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]